nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
direction les champs de bataille de
l'ukraine d'odessa haïr pinon passant
par micola ifs et kiev une de nos
envoyées spéciales a parcouru ce chemin
marqué par la guerre et la mort
gwendoline de bono bonjour vous êtes de
retour d'ukraine vous avez tourné seul
le reportage qu'on va découvrir vous
avez couvert d'autres zones de conflits
la syrie notamment qu'est ce qui
distingue les combats en ukraine d
autres terrains de guerre que vous avez
arpenté gwendoline mais la première
chose la première distinction c'est
qu'il s'agit d'une guerre de haute
intensité ce sont deux armées régulières
qui se font face pour moi c'était la
première fois que je couvrais ce type de
conflit alors une guerre de haute
intensité s'est énormément de moyens
engagés c'est aussi énormément de pertes
des deux côtés dans le reportage on s'en
rend compte par exemple à la morgue de
nicolay j'ai passé deux jours dans cette
morgue dans cet endroit il n'ya pas dix
minutes qui se passe sans que des corps
de soldats l'ukrainien soient amenés par
le cap par leurs camarades à la morgue
des corps de soldats russes aussi donc
ça permet de mesurer ce que ça signifie
un conflit de haute intensité et puis
l'autre chose très frappante c'est
l'esprit de défense d'une nation parce
que c'est vrai qu'une immense majorité
d'ukrainiens soutient son art mais sans
rôle où elle et ça c'est quelque chose
qui était extrêmement frappant également
et c'est d'ailleurs par sa queue va
commencer votre reportage qu'on découvre
tout de suite et puis on vous retrouve
juste après gwendoline de bono en
ukraine pour france 24
[Musique]
odessa 21h30 le train de nuit pour kiev
la capitale est à quai
l'un des passagers s'appelle vadim il a
20 ans
pour lui ce n'est pas seulement à trajet
vers une autre ville mais aussi vers une
autre vie
le
chagrine
[Musique]
c'est what has et michel il y avait le
temps je te mouilles nous mangeons
pas 'vide' tabou
nous apparaissons concerne un désastre
[Musique]
à la morgue de nicolas yves un soldat
tué par une frappe russe s'est placé
dans son cercueil par ses camarades
b
[Musique]
o o
sa mère vient juste de reconnaître son
corps
ne
soit ni témoignage c'était
un père observent en silence
il attend lui aussi de récupérer le
corps de son fils
jean auxerre chemin
[Musique]
sauber
il ne doit sa
capitale pour une image vaut d'ailleurs
les jo comme ça c'est bien pour ce clip
pour
lui de retrouver recentrer
les membres de l'unité de lexandre 22
ans ferme son cercle
les dépouilles de soldats ukrainien
arrivent sans cesse mais à la morgue
civils et combattants ennemis sont
mélangés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le spin 4 obligeant les pauvres tandis
que le sun ou bien aller à des tâches
incluent voyez mes petites dalles et
qu'il faut pas qu'ils allaient
pourtant plus détenant
à micola yves la mort s'annonce par le
bruit des obus souvent imprécis et par
celui des cirés
quand elle sonne le quotidien devient
souterrain
à la maternité les contractions crispe
les visages à force d'aller retour entre
les étages et le sous sol c'est aussi là
entre les canalisations et les locaux
techniques qu'il faut profiter des
premiers instants de vie eux sont
parents d'une petite adèle depuis
quelques heures seulement
ce
coffret chez
vous mais
déjà pas certain que vous êtes opposé à
tenir encore
une partie du sous sol sert également
d'abri aux habitants du quartier
l'équipe médicale occupe le fond du
couloir et elle s'adapte
au
big white de soins
bombyx des bosses erbakan side
de
[Musique]
cette femme vient d'accoucher d'une
petite fille par césarienne
[Musique]
au sous-sol l'alerté fini les femmes
remontent dans les étages
au fond de l'abri
lina une habitante du quartier fini sa
nuit
son voisin lui commence sa journée
le train de nuit partis d'odessa entre
en gare de kiev
[Musique]
vadim doit attendre deux jours avant de
rejoindre le fond
[Musique]
à la gare il retrouve karen involontaire
qui l'héberge pour l'instant
il accompagne une mère et sa fille qui
quitte la capitale elle habite un
quartier de kiev régulièrement bombardée
madonna qui anima bourhis que votre
avis
[Musique]
si un
premier mouvement ce guide
ir pin le front le plus proche de kate
la capitale se dessine après la forêt
[Musique]
cette route qui passe à travers bois
serbie et arras la connaît ce parc
ces deux ambulanciers volontaires
l'empreinte plusieurs fois par jour pour
aller sauver des habitants priso
tard à ses médecins en france il a
quitté la corse où il exerce quand la
guerra commence
ce jour là ils vont chercher plusieurs
familles bloquées dans les 3000
habitants sont encore en ville et aucun
quartier n'est chapeau fond
pensez y est
ce polar sera que
hors jeu d'un cran
les habitants sont conduits à kiev en
sécurité
deuxième trajet premier problème pour
serres qui est ta race pas s'approcher
pas ce qui est sucré pour eux ils
tiraient
on peut s'approcher
des combats s'engagent à proximité les
forces du craignait ne veulent repousser
les positions d'artillerie russe il faut
se mettre à couvert et attendre 15 20 25
minutes quand ça passe après
normalement ça quand on sait pourquoi on
cherche une cellule
[Musique]
la chaîne a fait pas d
autorisation est donnée de repartir
serbie fonce
arrivée d'henri repine il fait monter
ses enfants
la pâleur de leurs visages frappe ils
ont passé ces dernières semaines dans
une cave
la famille est évacuée
troisième appel des habitants attendent
l'ambulance être cru s'emboîtent alors
une salves de mortiers sur le point
d'évacuer
le premier déséquilibre tard les civils
sont en face il veut les faire monter
deuxième but
83e
les habitants attendent a couvert les
ambulanciers au
quatrième obus
il tombe dans la maison face à l'en but
tard à ce cri aux habitants de courir
dans l'en but
sur
balles
[Musique]
tara c'est sergei repartent malgré
l'appréhension
vingt minutes plus tard de retour à
l'arrière il répertorie les éclats sur
l'ambulance
avec le calme revienne aussi les
histoires et les visages de ceux qui ont
reçu la guerre de plein fouet
les deux visages de ces gens en civil
s'est
passé chaque box en sont dispensés sont
personnalité simone c'est une vie qui
est passé d une vie qui commence c'est
une vie qui va vers le même but que
s'est déroulé et tout ça c'est de trier
[Musique]
et on se retrouve avec gwendoline de
bono de retour d'ukraine gwendoline on
on vient de voir dans cette dernière
séquence le courage qu'il faut
secouriste pour aller chercher les
blessés sur le terrain les évacuer on
mesure à quel point les russes aussi
font un usage massif de l'artillerie
sans aucune
préoccupation pour les populations
civiles lorsqu'il tire là où vous vous
trouviez y avait-il un objectif
militaire
alors en fait il est assez difficile à
dire parce qu'à ce moment-là toute cette
zone est devenue une ligne de front
qu'est ce que les troupes russes visé
des soldats iraniens dans une maison à
ce qu'il visait une pièce d'artillerie
est-ce qu'il commençait à couvrir leur
retrait de toute cette zone nord ouest
de kiev c'est une possibilité en tout
cas ce que cette séquence montre c'est
effectivement le recours massif des
troupes russes à l'artillerie et ce
recours à la retirer il règle vraiment
la vie des ukrainiens qui vivent dans
les zones les plus exposées qui passent
des heures et des heures en sous-sol à
ans le voit également dans le reportage
notamment à la maternité de micola yves
mais c'est vrai que si vous voulez les
troupes russes encore une fois c'est
leur principal avantage ce recours à
l'artillerie le nombre de pièces
d'artillerie et qu'ils ont donc ils en
font usage et quand ils en font usage si
vous voulez qu'il y ait des ambulances
des civils des enfants des personnes
âgées à côté c'est le dernier de leurs
problèmes oui on voit aussi l'impact
psychologique sur ses sur ses victimes
évacuées alors le retrait des russes
dans certaines localités autour de kiev
notamment permet de découvrir
aujourd'hui l'ampleur des pertes civiles
et de potentiel massacres perpétués par
les russes ce qu'il nie vous qui étiez
sur le terrain qui avait recueilli des
témoignages
ça ne vous surprend pas
alors moi j'étais pas il ya quelques
jours dans ces localités de la ceinture
de kiev et bien sûr que ce qui nous
parvient de la est extrêmement choquant
mais il faut prendre le kremlin vraiment
au pied de la lettre quand il dit que
son objectif à la fin c'est de dainese
phil ukraine c'est vrai que tous les
ukrainiens qui ne sont pas pro russes
sont vus comme des pro nazi donc à ce
moment là on a tous les droits je me
suis rendu au milieu du mois de mars
dans une ville qui s'appelle bosnie
siège qui a été très brièvement occupée
par les russes pendant trois jours et là
déjà vous voyez on avait ce témoignage
dans toutes les maisons ont été pillées
les soldats russes fouillaient les
téléphones vidé à peu près toutes les
bouteilles d'alcool donc sans absolument
aucun garde-fou on parlait de ces
ambulanciers sont très courageux tout à
l'heure et bien une de leur équipe a été
kidnappé par les soldats russes qui leur
ont tendu un piège avec un faux appel
est un faux blessés donc le kidnapping
aussi à une pratique extrêmement
courante encore une fois ce discours
officiels russes qui déshumanise les
ukrainiens et bien sur le terrain on le
voit se traduire en actes à travers ce
que font les unités russes et qui sont
déployés en ukraine
et wayne de ligne de bono envoyé spécial
de france 24 de retour de kiev merci
gwendoline c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur françois
[Musique]